president Trump defends himself from
allegations he pressured Ukraine to
investigate Joe Biden Democrats ramped
up their attacks a quarrel over
impeachment and Elizabeth Warren surges
in Iowa straight from our brand-new ben
shapiro show studios this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
that's right folks we are not
broadcasting from the hellish box of
doom known as our prior studios I mean
that place was it was ghoulish it was a
terrible place I mean there were flies
everywhere you may have noticed during
the show and I was randomly batting at
the flies that was the thing that was
actually happening it wasn't just me
going crazy it smelled awful you can
never get the temperature control
exactly right
well now look at this magnificence ah I
can just feel the energy seeping into my
bones we're gonna get to actual material
in just one second I just have to
celebrate that for just one moment but
first there's a lot of talk of war with
Ron leading to increasing in
geopolitical insecurity skyrocketing
national debt and of course the Fed just
cut the interest rates which means it is
the perfect storm for a rally in gold
right now as people rush for more secure
assets is there any gold protecting your
portfolio and retirement savings it may
make some sense to include some precious
metals in your portfolio prevents
against central bank currency
manipulation and geopolitical
uncertainty well the way that I hedge
against inflation and uncertainty and
instabilities I buy some precious metals
some precious metals part of my
portfolio and the people that I trust
are the folks over at Birch gold my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be too right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax while you can even
move that IRA or eligible 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into gold or silver
which is perfect for people who might
want to protect hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty if you look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold does tend to
safeguard savings contact Birch gold
group get a free information kit on
physical precious metals ask them all
your questions get your answers and see
if diversifying its gold and silver
makes sense for you again get that
comprehensive 16-page kit revealing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
to get that no-cost no-obligation kit
simply text Ben to 47 47 47 again text
my name Ben to 47 47 47 Ben to 47 47 47
okay so the big story of the day is the
continued fallout from the whistleblower
report that has not yet been revealed
remember we still don't know what's in
this whistleblower report so to
recapitulate for folks who may not have
been following this story with all of
its requisite gravity so here is the the
story the story is that there was a
whistleblower inside the intelligence
community inform the Inspector General
of the intelligence community that there
was some sort of urgent violation that
had taken place if
this violation had been deemed urgent it
would have had to be reported to
Congress so the whistle the Inspector
General says you're right it is urgent
and then declares that this is gonna go
to Congress at this point the Director
of National Intelligence the Acting
Director of National Intelligence steps
in and he said well hold up just a
second this isn't urgent under the
applicable law because under the epical
law typically for a whistleblower
complaint to be deemed urgent it has to
deal with actual intelligence it can't
just be that the intelligence community
heard about something criminal that's
bad that's going on that doesn't
actually have to do with the
intelligence community and then reported
it to the inspector general and then
reported it to Congress instead it has
to deal with the actual intelligence
community well supposedly this report
didn't have to do with the Intel
community at all it had to do with
President Trump on the phone with
Ukraine so the Democrats immediately
shift to this is a cover-up
obviously Trump is trying to hide
something and then we get a kind of slow
leak about the information that was in
this whistleblower report so what was in
the whistleblower report well
the whistleblower report all that we
know so far is that President Trump had
conversations with the president of
Ukraine and supposedly in those
conversations the President of the
United States repeatedly suggested that
the Ukrainian government investigates
Joe Biden why well because Joe Biden and
hunter Biden father-and-son relationship
they have a nexus with Ukraine hunter
Biden was made the was made the CEO or a
board member of some organization in
Ukraine called Purisima in Ukraine at
the same time that Joe Biden was
pressuring via cranes who fire a to to
fire a prosecutor who was overseeing the
hunter Biden case so the scandal which
started to break maybe earlier this year
last year that scandal was supposedly
the Joe Biden had personally attempted
to hold up 1 billion dollars in loan
guarantees to Ukraine until Ukraine
fired a prosecutor that prosecutor was
overseeing hunter Biden's possible
investigation at the time so now
President Trump comes along and he's
apparently telling the Ukrainian
president you know I'd be great so then
ski it'd be great if you just
investigate Joe Biden because I mean did
anyone really invest now look the Trump
campaign has for months but in tempting
to push the Ukrainian government to
investigate Joe Biden and this is not a
secret rudy giuliani's been going over
there for a year trying to investigate
himself
operate with government sources in
Ukraine to find out whether in fact
hunter Biden was under investigation by
this prosecutor and whether Joe Biden
exerted his authority in order to hold
back American taxpayer dollars to get
the prosecutor ousted to protect his son
hunter and there are all sorts of
serious questions to be asked about Joe
Biden's relationship with hunter Biden
because as it turns out hunter Biden has
led a rather dissolute life and hunter
Biden has taken serious advantage of the
fact that his dad happens to be Joe
Biden he's gotten a series of cush
positions in which he has paid hundreds
of thousands of dollars basically
because daddy was a senator and then a
vice president so we're gonna get into
those allegations in just a second well
president Trump over the weekend came
out and he said yeah you know I I did
talk with Ukrainians about Joe Biden but
that is not a big deal according to the
New York Times president Trump
acknowledged on Sunday he raised
corruption al accusations against former
vice president Joseph R Biden Jr during
a phone call with Ukraine's leader a
stunning admission according to the New
York Times as pressure mounted on
Democrats to impeach Trump over
allegations he leans on a foreign
governments to help damaged a political
rival in public and in private many
Democrats said the evidence that has
emerged in recent days indicating that
mr. Trump pushed the Ukrainian
government to investigate mr. Biden and
his administration's stonewalling of
attempts by Congress to learn more or
changing their calculations about
whether to charge him with articles of
impeachment the influential chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee who has
resisted such action said the house
might now have crossed the Rubicon in
light of the new disclosures so that
would be Adam Schiff who came out and
said the Rubicon may have been crossed
we may now have to look at impeaching
President Trump over all of this so here
is Adam Schiff saying as much you know I
have been very reluctant to go down the
path of impeachment but if the president
is essentially withholding military aid
at the same time that he is trying to
browbeat a foreign leader into doing
something illicit that is providing dirt
on his opponent during a presidential
campaign then he may force us to go down
this road I have spoken with a number of
my colleagues over the last week and
this seems different in kind and we may
very well have crossed the Rubicon here
okay well the Rubicon that he is noting
is something that has not been shown yet
so as I explained last Friday when this
whole thing came up and last Thursday if
President Trump engaged in an actual
quid pro quo if he did
what he's accusing Joe Biden of doing if
he said to the Ukrainians 250 million
dollars in military aid is not
forthcoming unless you investigate Joe
Biden that is using American taxpayer
dollars for a campaign quid pro quo that
is obviously a violation of law it is it
is violation of bribery statute and
president Trump should be impeached and
really that a quid pro quo with a
foreign government to investigate your
political rival is in fact a violation
of law and impeachable if however this
is just Donald Trump getting on the
phone and saying to the cranes you know
it'd be great if you guys really
investigate you Abidin you know that'd
be great is that impeachment well that
is not what Adam Schiff is saying right
there right Adam Schiff is saying no not
so much right you're Adam Schiff himself
is saying the quid pro quo has to be
there
well why because President Trump has a
rather bad habit of mouthing off as you
may have noticed because he is a man
named Donald Trump who does very Donald
Trump like things has it turned out well
Jim Garrity has a piece over at National
Review in which he talks about this and
he's correct he says Donald Trump
believes just about everyone he doesn't
like must be corrupt or engaged in law
breaking of some manner and should be
investigated earlier this week he
tweeted out look at the Obama book deal
or the ridiculous Netflix deal then look
at other deals made by the Dems in
Congress the Congressional slush fund
and lastly the IG reports take a look at
them those investigations would be over
fast
so unlike Obama's book deal investigated
he wanted his Netflix deal investigated
Trump indicated that law enforcement
should investigate the Clintons over
Jeffrey Epstein he called for an
investigation of corrupt government in
Baltimore he suggested that Elijah
Cummings should investigate himself he
called on law enforcement to subpoena
all records having to do with the
Clinton Foundation this is all since
July read president Trump is constantly
asking people for investigations mainly
because he's been subjected to a lot of
investigations and so he's like well
turnabout is fair play he's twice called
on the FEC and the FCC to investigate
whether the whether Saturday Night Live
is colluding with the Democratic Party
so Jim garetty's point over a National
Review he says you notice that few of
these calls for investigation lead to
any investigations right it's reasonable
to worry about the politicization of law
enforcement at a moment like this but so
far there's not much evidence for it he
said what's more Trump speaks constantly
as if he's convinced that some sort of
colossal ruinous scam
is lurking behind each one of his foes
and all of them could be ruined if
federal investigators could look just
hard enough so it shouldn't be the least
bit surprising that Trump and allies
like Rudy Giuliani believe that hunter
Biden's work for a giant gas company in
Ukraine must be not merely unsavory or
created the appearance of a conflict of
interest but somewhere along the line
the Biden's must have broken the law
should the President of the United
States repeatedly call for law
enforcement investigations of his
political enemies based upon rumors
media reports and his own theories no of
course not but Donald Trump does a lot
of those kinds of things does this enter
a different area if the president is
promising X to foreign officials in
exchange for an investigation well
depends on the specifics as Jim Garrity
he says that insert Trump fo here is a
real crook everybody knows that
everybody's saying so if you guys caught
him and nailed him to the wall I'd be
thrilled
it's probably just Trump being Trump of
it honestly like if you had to Ballpark
what Trump said in this conversation do
you think it was more along the lines of
you know we got this 250 million dollars
in a and maybe it's worth coming and
maybe it's not I don't know but if you
just investigate Joe Biden its
forthcoming do you think it's that or do
you think that it's do you think the
conversation went something like this
zalinsky is the head of Ukraine lemis
the pleasant ingrateful speak to and
from going you know I hate yeah bad is
the worst gonna investigate him and so
once keep being like no we're not doing
that and trumping like but it'd be great
if you'd had Lenski me well no I'm
coming okay how's everything else going
I mean that like which sounds more like
Trump and a lot of the testitude with
whether you see President Trump as a
serious thinker like a person who thinks
through the things he says or a guy who
just says stuff it's very difficult to
square the sort of 4d chess president
Trump that so many people have in their
heads on the right and the forty chest
Trump that so many people I'm left
having their heads right they
simultaneously will claim that he's an
idiot and mastermind with who Trump is
in reality which is a guy who says lots
of stuff as I have said before president
Trump's tombstone one day will
eventually read Donald Trump 45th
President of the United States he sent a
lot of crap right that that is what
President Trump does and frankly I think
the president Trump would say the same
thing to like Emmanuel macron I think
he'd get on the phone with the Prime
Minister of France and microvilli me
stop Lizzie there how are you
and he's and Trump be like can you
investigate you abadan I'm a chrome be
like I don't know what you're talking
about
and from an eclair and an a French is it
right we're not two granion and like but
yes had the same to me
like the chances that Donald Trump was
seriously offering a quid pro quo to the
Ukrainians and now take for Thought
coming me a little bit skeptical of all
that nonetheless this is driving at the
narrative today Nancy Pelosi has issued
a letter to her colleagues and in the
house basically suggesting that
impeachment may be on the table in the
near future
it says Dear Colleague on Thursday
Acting Director of National Intelligence
Joseph McGuire will appear before the
House Intelligence Committee in an open
hearing at that time we expect him to
obey the law and turn over the
whistleblowers full complaint to the
committee we also expect that he will
establish a path for the whistleblower
to speak directly to the House and
Senate intelligence committees as
required by law
the intelligence community Inspector
General who was appointed by President
Trump has determined that the complaint
is both of urgent concern incredible and
its disclosure relates to one of the
most significance and importance of the
Director of National Intelligence --is
responsibilities to the American people
the administration's blocking of Acting
DNI McGuire from provide providing
Congress with the whistleblower
complaint calls upon him to violate the
federal statute which unequivocally
states that the DNI shall provide
Congress this information well it also
has conditions under which the
information is to be provided including
that it has to deal with the
intelligence community not with the
president the administration is
endangering our national security and
having a chilling effect on any future
illicit whistleblower who sees
wrongdoing we must be sure that the
president and his administration are
always conducting our national security
and foreign policy in the best interest
of the American people not the
president's personal or political
interest yeah well okay that sure it
would be great if Congress did that you
know what else would be great
if Barack Obama had not pledged
flexibility to the Russians in the
run-up to the 2012 election it would've
been great if Teddy Kennedy back in the
1980s had not been working with the
Russian government to undermine Ronald
Reagan it would have been fantastic if
Hillary Clinton had not been working
with yes the Ukrainian government to dig
up dirt on president Trump make to
pretend that that the area of foreign
policy is where all of the all of the
honor of the American people still
resides yeah not so much
not
much I'm old enough to remember when
Nancy Pelosi was traveling to the Middle
East 200 to undercut george w bush's
foreign policy so anyway she says I'm
calling on Republicans to join us in
insisting that the Acting TN I obey the
law as we seek the truth to protect the
American people
and our Constitution this violation is
about national security if the
administration persists in blocking this
whistleblower from disclosing to
Congress a serious possible breach of
constitutional duties by the president
they'll be entering a grave new chapter
of lawlessness which will take us into a
whole new stage of investigation
thank you for your patriotism best
regards Nancy so a couple of things one
I honestly think that we should find out
what exactly the whistleblower is
complaining about so I think the
Republicans probably should work with
Nancy Pelosi to pry loose this
whistleblower complaint if if the Trump
administration provides no clarity on
what happened here but there are a
couple of details that are being left
out of a lot of the reporting here and
we do need to mention them we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about your sleep quality so the fact is
that you've done all the right things
you've got a good mattress and you've
got you made sure that your room is dark
and it's the right temperature you're
still having trouble sleeping
maybe the reason is because you bought
sheets from the local gas station and
the garbage you're sleeping under a tarp
what you really should be using is bowl
and branch I love my bowline branch
meting I love it so much that I actually
tossed out all of our other bedding and
we only have Boleyn branch in our house
it kind of ruins Heather bedding for you
it's that good everything Boleyn branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton they start
out super soft they get even softer over
time you buy directly from them so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to
$1,000 in the store but Boleyn branch
sheets are only a couple of hundred
bucks shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights there's no risk no reason
not to give them a try tribal and branch
eats you will indeed love them they are
fantastically fantastically comfortable
and actually a more comfortable longer
you have them to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bol and branch
comm promo code Ben go to bull and
branch comm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets which takes a two
hundred dollar set of sheets down to 150
that is bol and branch com promo code
Ben again bull and branch com promo code
Ben go check them out right now okay so
a couple of details about this
whistleblower complaint cuz remember we
still don't actually know what Trump
said in the conversation so all of this
is speculation we do know
that Trump said something about Jeb
adding to the Ukrainian president the
Ukrainian president then came out and
said no I didn't initiate an
investigation so this sounds a lot like
the second half of the Mulla report
honestly so the second half of the Mulla
report was Donald Trump saying to
everyone in earshot
this is my league isin nine can we can
we get rid of him and every going nope
and Trump going alright and then sort of
moving on with his life for the next
month and then he comes back and is like
you know that knows me rabbit mother and
thereby going well leave him alone mr.
president all right and they just huh
nothing about this sounds exactly like
Daddy says till Solinsky can you go
investigate Joe Biden and solinsky's
like no nice my plans today I'm not
doing it in terms like okay and they
just sort of moves on yeah there's
another problem is that the
whistleblower here we thought I mean if
you'd read those reports on Thursday and
Friday it sounds like the whistleblower
was listening in on the phone call with
Donald Trump and Solinsky the president
of Ukraine as it turns out not so much
according to CNN the whistleblower
didn't have direct knowledge of the
communications didn't have direct
knowledge of the communications instead
the whistleblowers concerns came in part
from learning information that was not
obtained during the course of their work
okay well then how is he making an in in
intelligence whistleblower claim he
didn't gain the intelligence through the
intelligence process nor does it have to
do with intelligence sources and methods
those details have apparently played a
role in the administration's
determination that the complaint didn't
fit the reporting requirements under the
intelligence whistleblower law the
official said it's hard to know the
potential exposure faced by the
president so we still don't like that's
kind of amazing right that would have
been a detail that we should have known
because originally on Wednesday when the
Washington Post broke this report they
referenced a promise Trump allegedly
made to Ukraine but no we're beyond that
have we actually heard what the promise
was instead we've heard a lot of Trump
solicit solicitation right in the same
way that Trump publicly solicited
Vladimir Putin to put Hillary Clinton's
emails out there I mean that was not
really like a secret he went out on the
campaign trail that if you got the
emails break them do it love it live it
okay but so is this anything new now is
it bad of course it's bad the President
of the United States should not be
calling on foreign leaders to
investigate his political opponents yes
that's a bad thing also as I mentioned
among the other
bad things that presidents have done but
that are not impeachable Barack Obama
caught on tape pledging the Russians
flexibility in the in the lead-up to the
2012 election Hillary Clinton working
openly with the DNC and members of the
Ukrainian government to dig up dirt on
president Trump okay so lots of bad
stuff happens here and all of it is
worthy of condemnation the question here
is whether something criminal happened
that is worthy of impeachment
okay so President Trump has now
responded to all of this he said we'll
consider releasing some details of the
phone calls
he said the conversation by the way was
absolutely perfect this is clip 1 as far
as my conversation was perfect it was a
perfect conversation it was it couldn't
have been any better but we'll make a
determination about how to release it
releasing it saying what we said was an
absolutely perfect conversation perfect
10 conversation they can 19 remodel a
beautiful perfect unbelievable
conversation it wasn't just a good
conversation guys it was the best
conversation the greatest of all
conversations I mean like Socrates
versus Socrates versus his various
interlocutors not even close Donald's
from wit Celyn the perfect conversation
of the greatest and then President Trump
says but then I would have heard bad
okay this is where you start going okay
mr. president let's let's not go too
thick on the on the peanut butter here
there's President Roh Vice President
Biden did a terrible thing the way he
put it I'm not looking at to hold him to
anything I'm not looking to hurt him
with respect to his son Joe's got a lot
of problems there's got enough problems
without that but what he said was a
terrible thing there was no pressure
that was not pressure I I know when I
give pressure and that was not pressure
okay so President Trump then went on a
rampage on Twitter explaining all of
this said now the fake news media says I
pressured the Ukrainian president at
least eight times during my telephone
call with him I'm gonna read this in
straight voice I can't do Trump poised
for the next eight paragraphs I mean
there's a five paragraph essay he says
this supposedly comes from a so-called
whistleblower who they say doesn't even
have a first-hand account of what was
that more Democrat crooked media con
breaking news the Ukrainian government
just said they weren't pressured at all
during the night
all sleepy Joe Biden on the other hand
forced a tough prosecutor out from
investigating his son's company by
threat of not giving big dollars to
Ukraine that's the real story now the
Democrats in the fake news media have
gone bust on every other of their
witch-hunt schemes they're trying to
start run just as ridiculous as the
others called the Ukraine witch-hunt
while at the same time trying to protect
sleepy Joe Biden will fail again the
thick news media and their partner the
Democratic Party I mean I told you this
thing's a book the fake news media and
their partner the Democratic Party once
he stay as far away as possible from the
Joe Biden demand that the Ukrainian
government fire a prosecutor who was
investigating his son or they won't get
a very large amount of US money so they
fabricate a story about me and a
perfectly fine and routine conversation
I had with the new president of Ukraine
nothing was said that was in any way
wrong but Biden's demand on the other
hand was a complete and total disaster
the fake news knows this but don't want
to report the radical left Democrats and
their fake news media partners headed up
by little Adam Schiff and batting zero
for 21 against me are added again they
think I may have had a dicey
conversation with a certain foreign
leader based on a highly partisan
Whistleblower statement strange that
with so many other people hearing or
knowing of the perfectly fine and
respectful conversation that they would
not have also come forward do you know
the reason why they did not because
there was nothing said wrong it was
pitch perfect another fake news story
out there it never ends virtually any
time I speak on the phone to a foreign
leader I understand that there may be
people listening from various US
agencies not to mention those from the
other country itself no problem
knowing all of this is anyone dumb
enough to believe I would say something
inappropriate with a foreign leader
while on such a potentially heavily
populated call I would only do what is
right anyway and only too good for the
US and then later he made more remarks
about all of this he said the problem is
when you're speaking to foreign leaders
you don't want foreign leaders to feel
they shouldn't be speaking openly and
good you have to hit you have to be
talking to people and the same thing for
an American president you want them to
be able to express themselves without
knowing that not every single word is
going to be out and going all over the
world now this is fair okay this
particular critique that Trump is making
is absolutely fair right the President
of the United States has a lot of
conversations that are not meant for
public scrutiny a lot of conversations
of the foreign leaders in which highly
classified stuff is said you do want him
to be able to have open conversations
without whistleblowers going and and
seeing a political problem and then
reporting that to the legislative branch
because the president is indeed the
commander in chief so all of that
happens too
be true and having whistleblowers who
are making complaints that have nothing
to do with the intelligence community
which is the actual maybe problem here
is a serious problem but to go to the
core of it President Trump is basically
saying I did nothing wrong
there was no quid pro quo Rudy Giuliani
then said the same thing Giuliani went
on Twitter
he said whistleblowers still he said he
said whistleblower story Mike Kavanagh
story is blowing up
no no mention of money or quid pro quo
so appropriate conduct now we must look
at Biden family pattern of corruption of
selling his public offices for five
decades pattern of corruption enabled by
swamp okay so the Republican Trump
administration position is trumped enjoy
anything wrong the person who did
something wrong here is Joe Biden and
Joe Biden is just sitting there like
what did i do man why am I even part of
this story and the answer is you're part
of the story because your relations with
your son hunter are a problem for your
campaign make a real problem according
to the Washington Post this morning a
whistleblower complaint about president
from made by an intelligence official
centers on Ukraine according to two
people familiar with the matter which
has set off a struggle between Congress
and the executive branch Jim Garrity
says if the discussion is about Ukraine
it probably revolves around the Trump
campaigns interest in what hunter Biden
did for Ukrainian companies in the tail
end of the Obama administration and
Garrity says when the Obama campaign was
vetting Joe Biden to be vice president
in the summer of 2008 one of the most
sensitive issues they examined was the
relationship between the senator and his
family connection to a large Delaware
bank called MBNA the bank was the
largest donor to Biden's campaigns over
his career hunter hired one hunter Biden
in 1996 made hunter a vice president by
1998 when he was 28 years old hunter
departed to do a short stints in the
Department of Commerce they kept a
hundred thousand dollar-a-year retainer
from the bank after returning to the
private sector as a lawyer in Washington
working for a lobbying firm the Biden's
insist that hunters lobbying work never
cross paths with his father's work in
the Senate but during this time joe
voted in favor of a bankruptcy reform
bill that MBNA and other banks supported
and that many Democrats including
then-senator Barack Obama opposed right
Elizabeth Warren will probably at some
point jump in here when you're the son
of a famous senator or VP doors keep
opening for you by 2014 hunter bite
inhibit of ice Bank vice-president
lawyer partner two mergers and
acquisitions for him attempted to
purchase
hedge-fund found in two consulting firms
and shortly after his father started his
second term as vp joined the US Naval
Reserve that ended badly he was
discharged after about a year for
failing a drug test well get some more
of hunter Biden and why this could in
fact the scandal could in fact blow back
on Joe Biden and make Elizabeth Warren
the nominee we'll get to that in just
one second first look around you on the
road right now what you are seeing is a
myriad of cars and ask yourself if your
car broke and you went to an auto parts
store but they have the exact part that
you are looking for the fact is that you
might wait in line at this auto parts
store get to the front and then you get
a generic part that doesn't actually do
what you need it to do and it's
overpriced at that this is why you
should be using something called the
interwebs it is fantastic and you should
be clicking on over to Rock Auto calm
and it's a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
your daily driver get everything you
need in a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the rockauto.com
catalog is super easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and filter by brands and
specifications and prices best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got terrific selection they've
got amazingly low prices all the parts
your car will ever need Rock Auto calm
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro
and then how did you hear about us box
they know that we sing it that helps us
that helps them go check them out at
Rock Auto calm and make sure you write
Shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box ok so back to hunter Biden so
this whole subject of Investigation that
Trump wants and of controversy that
started all this stuff is hunter
relation hundred Biden's relationship
with Joe hunter has had a very checkered
life in a very checkered career and he
relied heavily on his dad's help
returning to the investment world rights
chimp charity Biden's business partners
included Jonathan Lee who ran a Chinese
private equity firm Bohai capital in
April 2014 at age 44 hunter Biden joined
the board of directors for Purisima
Holdings the largest non-governmental
run natural gas company in Ukraine not
everyone in the Obama administration was
comfortable with hunter's new business
partners according to The New Yorker
quote hunter's meeting with Lee and his
relationship with BH are attracted
little attention at the time but some of
Biden's advisors were worried that
hunter by meeting with a business
associate during his father's visit
would expose the VP to Curtis
the former senior White House aide said
that Hunter's behavior invited questions
about whether he was leveraging access
for his benefit which just wasn't done
in that White House optics really
mattered and that seemed to be cutting
it pretty close even if nothing
nefarious was going on apparently
several members of Biden's staff said
that they had been too intimidated to
talk to Joe Biden about all of this
everyone who worked for him has been
screamed at a former adviser told me
others said they were wary of hurting
his feelings
one business associate told me that
Biden during difficult conversations
about his family got deeply melancholy
which to me is more painful than if
someone yelled and screamed to me it's
like you've hurt him terribly
that was always my fear that I'd be
really touching a very fragile part of
him at the very least Hunter's business
dealings created the appearance of a
conflict of interest and that was true
also with regard to Ukraine there's a
perception that hunter was on the loose
potentially undermining his father's
message when he took a role at Purisima
in the 2018 appearance before the
Council on Foreign Relations
Biden described the time he threatened
withhold foreign aid from the Ukrainian
government unless they fired a
prosecutor named Victor Shokan the
argument from the Obama administration
is that shokan was resisting reform
efforts but one of the problems is that
he was preparing a corruption probe into
buries my holdings which was hunter
Biden's hunter Biden's company way that
hunter Biden was on the board of
directors so all of this could come back
just in time to truly bite Joe Biden
directly on the but and that could be a
real problem meanwhile Democrats are of
course ramping up impeachment talk they
are getting very frustrated many of the
more shall we say enthusiastic members
of the Democratic Party have been
pushing for impeachment for a while and
now they're really ramping up their game
you saw Adam Schiff already saying well
if there's a quid pro quo maybe we'll
talk impeachment well very unlikely they
uncover a quid pro quo you see Nancy
Pelosi
suggests that we are entering a grave
new era of lawlessness which again is
not calling for impeachment but is
drawing closer to it
you've got Elizabeth Warren who is the
odds-on favorite to become the next
Democratic nominee at this point gets a
polling in a second here she is
yesterday calling for impeachment of
President Trump over these allegations
Congress failed to act and now Donald
Trump has shown that he Wiz he believes
he is above the
he has solicited another foreign
government to attack our election system
it is time for us to call out this
illegal behavior and start impeachment
proceedings right now now of course the
impeachment goes nowhere because you'd
actually have to have proof of a crime
in order to get a majority well you need
to 60 votes in the in the Senate in
order to actually ask the president from
office so likely an impeachment vote
succeeds in the house but does not
succeed in the Senate of the United
States but Democrats at this point are
starting to warm up to all of this as we
get closer to 2020 they're making the
calculation there won't be blowback if
the story is bad enough and unlike the
Trump Russia allegations where there was
some smoke but no fire in the end as it
turned out here they can say that the
conversation itself is really the
problem that there's something very bad
and there is something bad about going
to a foreign government and asking them
to investigate your political opponent
now as I've said in the past there are
lots of various candidates particularly
Democrats who have gone to foreign
sources for information on their
opponents have made offers to try and
undercut Republican presidents yeah
that's nothing new but this the the
question for Democrats is politically
whether this appears to be serious
enough that they finally have the
momentum to go after President Trump on
impeachment on all of this
AOC and she tweeted out that the like
ripping into fellow Democrats the
question is how long an see Pelosi can
withstand the internal pressure AOC
tweeted out at this point the bigger
national scandal isn't the president's
law-breaking behavior it is the
Democratic Party's refusal to impeach
him for it and you're starting to see
this exact line gain momentum now as I
say the Democrats have yet to make a
case that Trump actually did something
illegal here and we'll see Renato
Mariotti legal affairs columnist for
Politico trying to stretch and twist and
turn to get to why this is impeachable
even though it's not criminal we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that when you go to
a business gathering one of the easy
ways to make an impression is your
business card but you probably have that
old business card they got from the
Kinkos like 20 years ago when Kinkos was
a serious thing and now you're walking
around with this beat-up old piece of
bait what you really need is a
nice-looking business card I can tell
you then when someone hands me a
business card if it is indeed a
nice-looking business card there's a
better shot that it ends up in my
rolodex as opposed to in my jeans pocket
going through the washing machine this
is why you should check out
vistaprint Vistaprint allows you to omit
the now for ten bucks for just ten bucks
mister print gives you 500 personalized
cards with exactly the look you want
that's a low price to make a lasting
impression and because you can choose
the colors fonts designs images well
that means you can create something as
unique and compelling as your business
as if you needed more reasons to choose
this to print it also happens to be
environmentally friendly which is cool
and your satisfaction is 100% guaranteed
or your money back
they will make it right if it's wrong
vistaprint wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation and that's why
our listeners are gonna get free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity just go to vistaprint.com
enter promo code Shapiro's - for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity limited time offer
only now at vistaprint.com promo code
Shapiro's - that is promo code shapiro
followed by the number to you support
our show when you support our sponsor so
please go give them a look
vistaprint.com promo code shapiro - to
let them know that we sent you alrighty
we're gonna get into the case that
Democrats aren't making on impeachment
even though no criminality has yet been
uncovered and we don't even know the
details of the whistleblower complaint
at this point we'll get to that in a
second first you have to go and
subscribe over at daily wire comm for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire comm and when you do you
get the rest of this show live when you
get the annual subscription you even get
this the best of beverage vessels look
at this the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler this tumbler is enjoying its new
beautiful studio surroundings and
helping us bring you the greatest in all
conservative commentary you get all
sorts of benefits by the way get to be
part of our mailbag which we used a lot
last week you get to be part of the
conversation you get to be part of the
are backstage live there all sorts of
benefits and there are more benefits
that are coming so when you subscribe
you get all sorts of amazing good plus
two additional hours of me a day so who
wouldn't want that except for my wife go
check it out over at daily wire comm
ninety-nine bucks a year will get you a
subscription we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so the the Democrats are trying to
broaden out the quid-pro-quo allegation
into a Trump did something impeachable
allegation and obviously impeachment is
not an actual legal standard all right
high crimes and misdemeanors is not a
legal standard meaning that lets say
that you impeach the president for
sneezing you can do that and that's not
challengeable in the Supreme Court so
Democrats can impeach Trump for whatever
they want but if they actually hope to
have a shot of asking him from office
and leaving vice president Pence as the
president of the United States
presumably the only way to do that would
be to actually uncover a crime well
Democrats have not yet done that renato
Mariotti is the legal affairs columnist
for Politico magazine former federal
prosecutor and he has a piece today in
Politico titled Trump didn't bribe
Ukraine it's actually worse than that
and here is where things start to get
dicey for the Democrats if they are just
saying that Trump behaved badly then you
have to start putting that into the
context of what have other presidents
done who behave badly but was not
impeachable and this is where it gets
dicey
so he says reports that Trump pressured
ukrainian President Vlad the Middle's
Lewinsky to investigate the son of
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden has prompted a flurry of
speculation that trump by withholding
military aid has committed bribery or
extortion this is wrong and even
counterproductive to efforts to hold
Trump accountable if what Trump is
accused of doing is true it is a kind of
corrupt conduct that the criminal system
is not equipped to handle labeling his
behavior with criminal terms such as
bribery and extortion
not only misunderstands the statutory
language against Trump in his supporters
ammunition with which to defend
themselves making impeachment harder to
achieve
he says the impulse to label this as a
potential crime is flawed legally and
even strategically even if true this is
not a case that would end up in a
criminal proceeding even if Trump were
no longer in office so he says you know
president's push foreign governments to
take official acts all the time the
Constitution contemplates the president
will interact with foreign leaders and
use his or her power to persuade them to
do things that help the United States
what is abhorrence about the alleged
conduct here is not that Trump is
pushing a foreign government to do
something but rather that he might have
used his presidential power to get a
foreign government to help him win the
next election this is self-serving and
corrupt but it is difficult to think of
this alleged activity as extortion he
says it's hard to construe the alleged
conduct as a threat against Ukraine in
the manner contemplated by the extortion
statute this is not say there
crimes on the books that better match
what Trump is alleged to have done so
maybe it's a campaign finance crime but
he says what Trump is alleged to have
done is not a garden-variety crime it's
worse this again is a columnist named
Renata Mariotti who is the legal
correspondent for Politico he says what
Trump is alleged Tripp done is not
garden-variety crime it's worse it
involves misusing 250 million dollars in
aid appropriated by Congress for his
benefit okay now you are accusing him of
doing something you don't have a record
of him doing and he says that this is
not a criminal justice system issue then
it really is just a trump Behaving Badly
issue he says labeling Trump's alleged
conduct bribery extortion cheapens what
his alleged to have occurred and does
not capture what makes it wrongful it's
not a crime he invited a foreign nation
to influence the 2020 presidential
elections on the heels of a nearly
three-year investigation now here's
where it gets dicey for Democrats if
what you are suggesting we're not on
Mariotti is that inviting foreign
governments to affect the American
election is something deeply deeply
deeply wrong and I generally agree it is
then you do get into the Barack Obama
saying to the Russians in the run-up to
2012 that he would have greater
flexibility up to the election if they
would back off a little bit that is
obviously requesting official action
from the Russians that would benefit
Barack Obama electoral and as a vague
rule that sort of stuff does happen all
the time
a leaders Democrat and Republican look
for foreign policy wins that he can get
from their friends in the lead-up to an
election that's fairly regular what's
different here is that he specifically
asked him for an investigation into a
political rival but the investigation
never took place and apparently wasn't
even taken seriously by the Ukrainian
president
so taking sent Philippe Raines who is a
long held to be sort of a a hard-nosed
cutting biting brutal kind of hard-nosed
political agent for Hillary Clinton
who's Hillary Clinton's hatchet man for
a long time he was on Fox News he said
well your heads would explode if Hillary
did anything like this there is no
reason for Joe Biden's name to come up
in that conversation once twice eight
times whether it's promising threatening
quid pro quo demanding whatever it is
that is crossing the line and yes there
is a problem with that and what's a say
for a moment Hillary Clinton had won and
Donald Trump was challenging her again
next
and we were talking about Hillary
Clinton talking it to a foreign leader
to help her find dirt on one of the
Trump kids your heads would be exploded
yeah there's only one problem which is
that she literally did that in 2016 so
she wasn't the president at the time she
literally and the DNC literally
coordinated with the Ukrainian embassy
to try and dig up dirt on Donald Trump
Politico reported that in 2017 we talked
about it at extensive length last week
so if you missed last week's podcast
Hillary Clinton did do that and it
wasn't criminal it was bad it wasn't
criminal in the same way that Donald
Trump requesting that Vladimir Putin
release Hillary Clinton's emails was bad
but not criminal lots of stuffs been
happening folks that's bad but not
criminal Jake Tapper did sort of the
same thing and Jake's a good reporter
but he went after Steve minuites and
what if Democrats tried this sort of
stuff if for instance President Obama
had pressured a foreign leader Putin or
the president of Ukraine anyone said I
want you to look into Donald Trump jr.
or I want you to look into Eric Trump
international businessmen both of them
would you not find that inappropriate
again I'm not going to speculate on that
what I do find is inappropriate is the
fact that Vice President Biden at the
time son did very significant business
dealings in Ukraine I for one find that
to be concerning and to me that's the
issue perhaps that should be further
investing okay so the Trump campaign is
gonna keep pressing in on the hundred
Biden thing now that they are pursuing a
strategy that you've seen scott adams
who's the the Dilber creator and sort of
the Trump whisperer he suggested that
Trump often does this and meshes himself
in scandals where the headline that ends
up being elevated from the scandal is
actually deleterious to Democrats
so the Trump Russia stuff ended up
elevating Hillary's email scandal for
example so he would say that this whole
conversation ends up really hurting Joe
Biden most and I think there's a lot of
truth to that but to go back to the
point that if Obama asked a foreign
leader to investigate Donald Trump jr.
there the the allegation by Andy
McCarthy and others in the Republican
camp is that the Obama administration
literally coordinated to try and raise
dirt about Donald Trump and Russia in
the middle of the 2016 election they had
the entire Trump Russia election
conspiracy theory was being pumped by
Hillary Clinton funneled through Hillary
Clinton's campaign and fusion GPS to the
FBI
who then under the auspices of people
like Loretta Lynch investigated the
thing and that is the allegation from
the right so we don't have to speculate
about the rights reaction it would be
bad and the less reaction is similarly
bad and is any of that criminal not
really but it does underscore how dirty
things have gotten
generally speaking now who is the big
beneficiary from all of this it isn't
really Donald Trump right Donald Trump
is gonna be there's gonna be impeachment
talk and Ukraine talk it's certainly not
Joe Biden who is now gonna be dragged
into the center of this kicking and
screaming I mean the man already doesn't
know where he is people I mean he's
already what why are you taking me away
from the early bird dinner at Denny's
what were where are we now are we in
Ukraine the person who's gonna benefit
from all of this is Elizabeth Warren who
does have the momentum right now there's
a pull out from the Des Moines Register
CNN and Mediacom and it shows that
Warren has pulled it into a slight lead
in Iowa according to that poll she now
holds a two percentage point lead with
22 percent of likely Democratic caucus
goers saying she's their first choice
for president this is her first lead
former VP Biden who has led each of the
registers three previous 20/20 cycle
polls follows her at 20 percent Bernie
Sanders has fallen to third place with
11 percent she's drawing a lot to
support from Bernie this is why I've
been saying for a while that this is
gonna get fun at some point Bernie
Sanders must open up his socialist guns
on Elizabeth Warren and point out that
she is wildly wildly disingenuous the
president of Seltzer and company which
conducted the poll said this is a major
first major shake-up it's the first time
we've had someone other than Joe Biden
at the top of the leaderboard Peabody
judge follows the three leaders as the
favorite of nine percent of poll
respondents he's really running for vice
president at this point the race is far
from settled just one in five likely
Democratic caucus goers say their minds
were made up 63 percent say they could
still be persuaded to support a
different candidate but there's no
question that the momentum right now is
with Elizabeth Warren if you look at the
other state polls so Joe Biden
nationally has a pretty wide lead he saw
the 10-point lead nationally he's about
30 percent according to the Real Clear
Politics poll average Elizabeth Warren
is about 20 percent but if you look at
Iowa Warren has pulled it into about a
three point lead in the Real Clear
Politics poll average and the latest
polls from New Hampshire are still not
particularly recent the latest polls
from New Hampshire were taken November
number six to September 11th so about
two weeks ago before a lot of the search
and in that latest poll Biden was up on
Sanders just one and Warren just six so
there is a good shot that by this point
the next poll will show that Warren is
indeed up in New Hampshire as well would
be my prediction he's only up slightly
in Nevada to it's South Carolina where
where Joe Biden really has his has his
advantage but if you look at the
elections calendar it may be too late
for him by then because they remember
the Democrats in the aftermath of all
the hubbub about about Bernie Sanders
being jobs during the presidential
cabinet in 2016 they front-loaded all of
their caucuses he got the Iowa caucus
happening February third 2020 the New
Hampshire the New Hampshire primary
happening on February 11th 2020 you have
the Nevada presidential caucuses on
Saturday Saturday February 22nd and then
you have a South Carolina happening at
the 29th so maybe maybe if Joe Biden is
lucky if you're if you're forecasting
this and again we're months away so a
lot could happen you could have you
could have Elizabeth Warren when Iowa
win New Hampshire
you could have Biden come back and win
Nevada and South Carolina and then you
get Super Tuesday and Super Tuesday
I don't know that Biden has enough
momentum to run away with things he
probably wins the southern states he
probably wins Alabama he wins Arkansas
Elizabeth Warren probably wins
California she probably wins Colorado
she probably wouldn't mange she
certainly wins Massachusetts she
probably wouldn't Minnesota she probably
wins Oklahoma so it's gonna be it's
gonna be neck and neck I mean Biden is
really suffering and the fact is that as
this story about hunter Biden and Joe
Biden takes the front pages over that is
gonna be very bad because Elizabeth
Warren's entire stick of course is that
this was the swamp like now would be a
great time for Elizabeth Warren to
started attacking Joe Biden about that
MBNA Bank deal that hunter Biden was
part of again she's been anti the
banking industry she's got the
enthusiasm the media love her love her
so Joe Biden and Elizabeth Warren by the
way were also simultaneously campaigning
over the weekend in the same place say
they decided to go join the picket line
alongside striking General Motors worker
in Detroit Joe
I went to a GM assembly plant in Kansas
City Kansas because there's nothing that
the American people like better than
strikes the Democratic presidential
candidates according to the New York
Times have been chasing labor support
all summer
now as the UAW one of the nation's
largest unions stages a strike that has
drawn words of support from President
Trump Democrats are seizing the moment
to align themselves with workers in
public in traumatic ways senator
Elizabeth Warren walking at the picket
line Joe Biden doing it as well Bernie
Sanders is planning to join striking
workers in Detroit on Wednesday so that
they're all campaigning for the same
workers and they're making the case I
mean Elizabeth Warren is stopping by to
make the case that she is gonna make a
play for the white working-class vote
which is really an area where she is
lagging and she's got basically all of
the college-educated Democratic voters
want to vote for Elizabeth Warren a lot
of the white blue-collar workers want to
vote for Joe Biden and a lot of the
black folks in the united state black
voters want to vote for Joe Biden she's
trying to carve it into that right now
and she may be successful in doing that
and I think that if Trump's goal with
this with this Ukrainian stuff was to
tear down Joe Biden right now which
makes sense cuz he runs steadier against
Elizabeth Warren than Joba then Joe
Biden he may achieve his goal whether or
not the Democrats who want it okay
meanwhile Washington DC may be shut down
by climate rebels oh they're gonna bring
the city to a standstill now once again
do they have any actual program of
course not of course not
their goal is just to suggest that if
you don't that if you criticize them you
don't care about climate change which is
supremely irritating I mean they're
these climate change activists these
youth climate strikers like what are
they striking from going to school guess
what you won't being paid to go to
school you striking from your own
education is a problem for you but it's
not particularly smart but again we're
gonna pretend that this is all just an
act of true bravery that changes the
world yadda yadda yadda anyway they're
out there striking from again you can't
really strike from school because you're
not paid to go to school the schools
don't lose based on your not being there
and in fact many of the schools
incentivized kids to come to this sort
of thing where they just spouted their
emotions and we're supposed to take
seriously emotions if they come from 17
year olds so here are some of the
climate change activists admitting that
they have a paralyzing fear of the
future which makes sense considering
they're the freest most prosperous young
people in the history of humanity
to speak for the trees I'd like to
acknowledge my sublet in my background I
am here for the people who are suffering
and dying because of our country's
decision we do not have time to be
polite this is a revolution holy ok so
I'm first of all if my child acts like
that they get a timeout
ok well my five-year-old acts like this
she gets a timeout screaming into a
microphone whatever you don't even I
don't even know what you want I don't
even know what you want what do you want
okay you want the earth to not be as
warm what would you like us to do about
this this is my big problem and Barack
Obama of course incentivizes all this
sort of nonsense because this is the
kind of president he was as well he
tweeted out one challenge will define
the future for today's young generation
more dramatically than any other climate
change the millions of young people
worldwide who've organized and joined
today's climate Strike Command action to
protect our planet and they deserve it
what do they deserve demanding action
like what does that mean my daughter
demands action for me every morning and
I don't know what she wants if she just
comes in and says I demand action it's
like what do you want from me would you
like to get dressed
didn't you get you some food like what
are we talking about here and I'm sorry
but that is not political activism
that's just you screaming at things see
the thing is when you take a politically
active stance normally you have to have
a program attached to it when I speak at
the March for Life I'm pretty sure I
know what the March for Life folks want
I want more legislation to stop abortion
ok then they would like to defund
Planned Parenthood they have a specific
program you got to have a specific
program folks if you want people to take
you seriously but of course none of
these people have a specific program the
whole goal here is to morally castigate
people who point this out so you have
Bill Nye the supposed science guy saying
well you know it's time for a change
listen dude just because you like did
cool science experiments with baking
soda back when I was 11 does not mean
that you are proposing anything do
and that bowties is getting old so are
you greetings everyone Bill Nye here
Thank You students for getting out there
and calling attention to climate change
and the big changes that we need to make
to address it now we built this
remarkable society with this remarkable
infrastructure because of our use of
fossil fuels and sort of the fossil fuel
industry I say thank you for your
service but it's time to make big
changes and the students are reminding
us of that today we can do this
everybody we can change the world
okay what is do this and change the
world we can we can do it yeah yeah my
favorite part is really we built this
entire beautiful wonderful society where
I get to wear bowties on TV for money
we've built that on fossil fuels so
thanks for that also we're gonna just
totally destroy that and I have no
program well done everyone
you've really you've changed the world
today by saying nothing and just making
people angry or for no apparent reason
when there should be at least an attempt
it seems to me to come up with some sort
of workable solution it is such a point
of irritation when people do this sort
of stuff screaming at the moon doesn't
get things done it just does not okay
time for some things that I like and
then some things that I hate some things
that I like Karl Marlantes is a terrific
novelist he wrote a book called
Matterhorn about the Vietnam War and
about what it was like to fight in the
Vietnam War a few years back and it is
one of the finest books on the Vietnam
War ever written it really is terrific
he has a great new book called deep
river that hasn't gotten the sort of
attention that it should have received
about a a finished phantom family that
moves over to the to the Oregon area and
gets involved in logging and it's sort
of reminiscent of Ken Kesey sometimes a
great notion it's it's really a
well-written book I really love my
lances writing I think that he is a
terrific evocative writer he doesn't try
to hide the ball in his writing his word
choice is beautiful if you're into good
novels then deep river is one that I
would recommend even though I disagree
some of the politics in it it is well
worth the read go check it out deep
river by Carl Meyer Lansky other things
that I like I like that the comedic
community is beginning to come around to
the fact that canceled culture is going
to clock them directly in the face of
Sarah Silverman who is as woke as it is
possible to be while still being a very
very white slash Jewish person she says
that the host list shows that
like the Emmys are really terrible
because canceled culture is done anymore
in these shows they don't want comedians
to talk would you offer to step in no
nobody wants to do it either
I mean it's thankless absolutely correct
and then Stephen Colbert and Jimmy
Kimmel get up on stage and I mean I
can't believe this is like the Pope in
the anti Pope of leftism I guess there's
like a papal schism in comedy right here
take your side which one of these whoa
comedians would you prefer both of them
start mocking the hot of the hosts live
shows like guys you're part of the
problem like if you don't like the hosts
list shows then maybe you shouldn't
participate in the canceled culture that
is involved in destroying but but I do
like the fact that they're criticizing
at least how's the old no host thing
going what a dumb idea what a joke so
stupid you know it has the host
Applebee's has a host yeah that food too
we would have brought food yeah and now
you guys are gonna starve to death you
know who the real victims are here it's
us Hosting is the only thing we know how
to do
I'm sorry but this show sucks okay and
not only does it suck me that they're
trying to make a joke out of it and sort
of play both sides of this joke but um
that was the show did suck the Emmys and
the ratings were down dramatically
because as it turns out what culture is
garbage wokes cold culture is just the
worst it's the worst cancel culture is
garbage and even the left in comedy is
starting to look around going okay when
are they coming for me
yeah first they came for everybody else
and I laughed and I went along with it
now they're coming for me
feeding the alligator only means that
they get eaten last okay time for a
quick thing that I hate okay so Michelle
Williams was on at the Emmys where she
was wearing a very very expensive dress
and winning an Emmy as it turns out and
complaining about how she doesn't get
paid enough she gets paid millions of
dollars to be in pictures she's
particularly complaining because when
they reshot all the money in the world
because they had to write Kevin Spacey
out of history and then they replaced
him with Christopher Plummer and did a
lot of the reshoot she got paid like a
thousand bucks for the reshoot and Mark
Wahlberg got paid like 1.5 million
dollars for the reshoot that's because
he has a good agent her agent is crap
but instead of firing her agent she
decided to rail against the industry I
want to say thank you so much to FX and
to Fox 21 studios for supporting me
completely and for paying me equally
because they understood that when you
put value into a person it empowers that
person to get in touch with their own
inherent value and then where do they
put that value they put it into their
work and so the next time a woman and
especially a woman of color because she
stands to make 52 cents on the dollar
compared to her white male counterpart
tells you what they need in order to do
her job listening to her okay well you
know what Michelle Williams could do she
could just give up her jobs to women of
color because it turns out that women of
color can play like three-quarters of
the parts that she plays I don't see her
giving that up also she should talk to
her agent if she doesn't like what she
got paid and I'm sorry making Michelle
Williams the face of pay inequality the
woman's worth probably twenty million
dollars yeah I'm no no and but that
statistic that she's citing fifty two
cents on the dollar is a crap statistic
it has always been a crap statistic it
doesn't adjust for a number of hours
worked for job type for educational
level for years in the workforce for job
level it doesn't like doesn't adjust for
an
of that the fact that we are supposed to
listen to lectures from Michele Williams
about equal pay yeah take it up take it
up with CAA take it up with SIA already
we will be back here later today with
two additional hours of content and all
the updates you will ever need i'm ben
shapiro from our brand-new studios and
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessa
Vera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you